>> Sean: BIG BREAKING NEWS
MOMENTS AGO, VICTORIA
TOENSING THE ATTORNEY FOR
THE URANIUM ONE INFORMANT IS
CONFIRMING TO THIS SHOW
TONIGHT THAT IN FACT THE FBI
IS INVESTIGATING THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION AND MEANWHILE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THINK CAN DO TO
TRY TO DISCREDIT.
REMEMBER, THE INFORMANT,
THEY ARE SELECTIVELY LEAKING
INFORMATION TO THEIR FRIENDS
IN THE LEFT WING MEDIA.
WE ALSO HAVE OTHER BREAKING
NEWS FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS.
HE WAS ON LAST NIGHT WITH
OUR OWN SHANNON BREAM AND HE
SAID THAT HE IS SERIOUSLY
NOW CONSIDERING APPOINTING A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL, TICK
TOCK, WATCH THIS.
>> WELL, I HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR MR. GOWDY AND
CHAIRMAN GOODLATTE.
AND WE ARING
AND WE ARENG
AND WE ARE GOING IT CONSIDER
SERIOUSLY THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I HAVE APPOINTED OUTSIDE OF
WASHINGTON MANY YEARS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
LOOK AT ALL THE ALLEGATIONS
THAT THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENT TO US
AND WE ARE CONDUCTING THAT
INVESTIGATION.
I ALSO AM WELL AWARE THAT WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
FISA PROCESS.
WE ARE NOT AFRAID TO LOOK AT
THAT.
>> Sean: THIS IS HUGE NEWS.
JOINING US WITH REACTION, HE
IS THE CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE
CENTER OF LAW AND JUSTICE
AND ATTORNEY TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES JERRY JAY SEKULOW.
I WANT TO GO BACK, JARKS
OVER THESE COMMENTS, HE SAID
IN THE INTERVIEW LAST NIGHT,
I HAVE APPOINTED A PERSON
OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON, MANY
YEARS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, LOOKING AT THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENT US AND WE ARE
CONDUCTING THAT
INVESTIGATION AND HE STATED
HE IS WELL AWARE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE FISA
PROCESS.
THIS IS A HUGE DEVELOPMENT.
>> IT IS, SEAN.
AND I THINK THE IMPORTANT
PART TO FOCUS IN ON HERE IS
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SAID HE HAS ALREADY
APPOINTED SOMEONE WITH A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE OUTSIDE OF
WASHINGTON, D.C. WITH A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHO IS
ALREADY CONDUCTING AN
INVESTIGATION.
THAT INVESTIGATION, IN ALL
PROBABILITY, IS A
DETERMINATION BEING REVIEWED
AS AS TO WHETHER, IN FACT,
THAT SPECIAL COUNSEL, AS HAS
BEEN REQUESTED BY THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN CALLED
FOR BY MEMBERS OF THE UNITED
STATES SENATE.
BEEN CALLED FOR BY TRAY
GOWDY.
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IT FOR A LONG TIME.
WHAT'S HAPPENED RIGHT NOW IS
IT LOOKS LIKE THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE HAS APPOINTED
SOMEONE WITH A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE TO MAKE THE
DETERMINATION, AT LEAST MAKE
ADVICE AS TO THE
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER
A SPECIAL COUNSEL SHOULD BE
APPOINTED FOR THIS PRECISE
SITUATION.
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE FISA ABUSE WHICH IS SUCH
A BIG SCENARIO.
>> Sean: JAY, MY SOURCES AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR
THAT IN THEIR VIEW, I
DISAGREE WITH IT.
I THINK WE HAVE -- THERE IS
ENOUGH EVIDENCE THAT WE KNOW
NOW THAT WOULD WARRANT AND
JUSTIFY A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
BUT THE FEELING HAS BEEN WE
GOT TO WAIT FOR THE IG
REPORT TO COME OUT.
THEN, OF COURSE, DOJ
ATTORNEYS HAVE TO LOOK AT IT
THEN THEY WOULD CONSIDER THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
IT SEEMS UNBEKNOWNST TO
AWFUL THAT'S JEFF SESSIONS
WAS DOING A LOT MORE THAN
ANY OF US KNEW.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, WE TALKED
ABOUT THAT BEFORE.
THE PUBLIC DOESN'T ALWAYS
KNOW WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS DOING INTERNALLY.
REMEMBER, ACCORDING TO THE
REGULATIONS HERE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS A
PROCESS THAT THEY GO THROUGH
IN REVIEWING AS TO WHETHER A
SPECIAL COUNSEL SHOULD BE
APPOINTED.
NOW, HAVE YOU GOT TO HAVE AN
ISSUE OF ACCURATELY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN ISSUE OF
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
I THINK IN BOTH OF THOSE
SITUATIONS AS IT RELATES TO
THE FISA INVESTIGATION, IT
WARRANTS A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
AND IT APPEARS THAT WHAT
JEFF SESSIONS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS DONE HAS STARTED
THAT PROCESS INTERNAL REVIEW
BY THE WAY COULD DUAL TRACK
WITH THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE ONE
OR THE OTHER.
SPECIAL COUNSEL HAS A DEEPER
ABILITY TO TALK TO WITNESSES
OUTSIDE OF THE EXISTING
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
PERSONNEL, WHICH IS ONE OF
THE LIMITATIONS IMPOSED ON
AN INSPECTOR GENERAL.
SO I THINK THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT.
I THINK IT'S SIGNIFICANT FOR
THE RULE OF LAW AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT A FISA
SITUATION WHICH WAS BASED ON
A UNVERIFIED OR SALACIOUS IN
THE WORDS OF JAMES COMEY
DOSSIER.
THAT DOSSIER INFORMATION WAS
LEAKED TO THE PRESS.
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, WHO PUT
THAT DOSSIER TOGETHER, WAS
INVOLVED WITH BRUCE OHR,
NUMBER FOUR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WIFE
AS FAR AS WORKING SHE WAS
WORKING FOR FUSION GPS.
YOU STUART PUTTING THESE
TOGETHER AND THEN, OF
COURSE, HE ULTIMATELY GETS
FIRED, CHRIS STEELE, BECAUSE
HE LEAKED THE INFORMATION TO
THE PRESS.
NOW, DID THEY TELL THAT TO
THE COURT IN THE FISA
WARRANT?
I SUSPECT NOT.
BUT, AGAIN, THIS GOES TO THE
POINT THAT YOU HAVE A FISA
COURTS ARE VERY SERIOUS.
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
SURVEILLANCE ACT.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE PROCEDURES
IN PLACE TO PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS SPECIAL
COUNSEL NEEDS TO BE LOOKING
AT.
>> Sean: THE FISA LAW IS
VERY CLEAR.
FBI PROTOCOLS HAVE VERY
CLEAR THAT THEY HAVE LEGAL,
MORAL, ETHICAL, EVEN BY
THEIR OWN STANDARDS,
OBLIGATION TO VERIFY AND
CORROBORATE ANY MATERIALS
THAT ARE SENT BEFORE A FISA
COURT IT SEEMS TO ME THERE
WERE A LOT OF ISSUES AT PLAY
HERE AND EXONERATION BEFORE
AN INVESTIGATION, MONTHS
BEFORE.
THAT IS UNHEARD OF.
SECONDLY, IF YOU HAVE.
>> WITNESSES WERE GIVEN
IMMUNITY IN THAT SITUATION.
>> Sean: WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE COMPUTERS?
>> WELL, WAIT A MINUTE.
WITNESSES WEREN'T EVEN
INTERVIEWED.
I MEAN, AS FAR AS WHEN
THAT -- WHEN THE DRAFT OF
THE REPORT THAT WAS PUT
TOGETHER.
AND, REMEMBER THIS:  ANDREW
MCCABE SAID THAT THEY WOULD
NOT HAVE EVEN SOUGHT THE